[creator] Okay, so update the integrate and play test agent finished
[creator] It had issues actually merging though, so I had to get those fixed
[creator] So just had to run something in terminal so now I'm just waiting on it to
[creator] There we go. I'm just gonna say I'm waiting on it to be able to merge so we got that merge now perfect
[creator] and everything. Is the game ready to be played? And if so, can you open it in the browser?
[creator] Right here, I typed this in the wrong chat. All right, so this is Vesper Drift.
[creator] From a glowing pebble into a black hole, absorb what is smaller, avoid what is larger. Okay,
[creator] so it doesn't seem like it's a, I don't know, I was hoping for better. I'm also not hearing
[creator] any sound effects so definitely gonna need to add those so it's not perfectly
[creator] like drifter star just fine you also like full eye so fast but it does look
[creator] nice at least it's very similar I would like it to look better though definitely
[creator] need sound effects that's for sure like I should be able to chip away at the
[creator] that are larger and break them apart leaving the okay so it's not infinite
[creator] i've evolved into an asteroid nice okay it's pretty cool still a dwarf planet so got some
[creator] got some growing to do it's also there's a little bit of gravity i feel like there should be more
[creator] though like when i'm a lot larger than these other pieces they should be getting pulled in
[creator] but doesn't seem like that's really the case overall it's not
[creator] awful I mean I don't know what's up with the fire
[creator] like that's there should not be fire
[creator] I don't know why I'm just now like
[creator] noticing that it's not bad I can work with it
[creator] so yeah I'm gonna get some
[creator] sound effects added and fix some other stuff
[creator] I don't know if I'm gonna do that tonight because I kind of just want to chill
[creator] But yeah, that's the update